I've been making things certainly since
I was in a small school boy if you would
look around my workshop you'll see I've
got a number of machines none of them is
new usually I bought them as Rex and
I've rebuilt them so that occupies a lot
of my time I've always been really
interested in the ancient world and
ancient engineering when I'm making an
ancient instrument such as this
I am innate should work when in my own
mind the hammer I pick up might have
been made this century it might be made
last century there is but the use of a
hammer and the way I use it is exactly
the same as the Hellenistic myth I call
this the sphere of Archimedes that's
really not a formal name that for want
of anything better the sphere represents
the the sky the figures on it are the
constellations but it isn't just a
representation of the fixed stars in the
night sky in their constellations the
pointers show the positions in the sky
of the Moon the Sun and the five known
planets and they're all connected
together by some fairly simple gearing
which is inside the globe the reason I
call it the sphere of Archimedes is that
the earliest lecture the clearest
description of such an instrument that
we have is Cicero's account of an
instrument that he says was taken from
Syracuse when Archimedes was killed and
this instrument was supposed to have
been devised possibly made by Archimedes
himself in a sense what I've made is a
demonstration of what was possible in my
view to see how it works let me pull its
pieces
Open Sesame I think this instruments
really interesting because it helps
flesh out a tradition which hasn't
really been fully noticed by earlier
generations of scholars this tradition
of little instruments working with gear
wheels there was a busier industry of
small mechanical work than most of our
perception of ancient literature would
need us to believe could we call the
designer and the maker of an incident
like a sophisticated I'm not sure I know
well because we have so little of their
mechanical work even if we add together
all the reconstructions as have you made
but certainly it there is ingenuity
certainly there is ability certainly
there is very great cleverness and many
many people have published papers or
magazine articles or whatever about
ideas for how ancient machines worked
and often one looks at those articles
those papers and one thinks I bet he
hasn't tried it because it wouldn't work
I wanted to avoid that pitfall I I
wanted to avoid having anyone say he's
all talk he can't do it I can do it so I
enjoy doing it so that seems to me a
good way of demonstrating that the thing
should be taken seriously